hi there steve coffin here and today i'm
not going to talk about languages i'm
going to talk about ukraine
i have a number of videos that i have
recorded over the last 10 days or so
that will be appearing regularly on my
channel
i know there are those who will say that
i shouldn't talk politics on this
channel but we're not talking about
politics here we're talking about
right and wrong
truth and lies
we're talking about people's lives
and i can't not talk about the barbaric
invasion of ukraine by the russian army
by putin's russian army
an invasion that's based on lies
lie number one that ukraine somehow is a
nazi country let's just start with that
one
the president of ukraine is jewish the
defense minister is jewish the former
prime minister was jewish
i just finished seeing a video
where in 2019 some ukrainian with a big
cross hanging around his neck was
complaining about
gays and and lgbtq and this kind of
thing
and
zelensky president of ukraine said we
live in a free country we can choose our
language we can choose our identity we
can choose our sexual orientation leave
those people alone now does that sound
like the statement of a nazi is there a
leader in
russia who would say those things
ukraine is not a nazi country it is not
ruled by nazis
there are nazis in ukraine there are
nazis in russia there are nazis in the
united states in canada everywhere there
are some nazis however
a survey
of
uh where people in europe were asked
would you accept jews as your fellow
citizens or would you be opposed to it
ukraine is the most tolerant towards
jews so
nazi forget it
the second lie
used by putin to justify his war is
there is is that there is genocide
against russian speakers in ukraine
there is no genocide against russian
speakers in ukraine russian speakers are
at roughly half the population in other
words native speakers of russian i don't
know what the statistics are forty
percent fifty 50
significant number they are free there
is no genocide against those people
there was a war
in the dunbas a war that was started by
the russians it was led by russians
borodin gierkin
bessler
all kinds of so-called volunteers that
came in from russia to foment this war
fed this war
financed the war provided on an ongoing
continuing basis armaments to this war
in the on the territory of another
sovereign country ukraine the war in the
donbass was created by russia and during
that war
2014
yes
there was there were rockets fired from
the ukrainian side into the sort of
separatist held areas there were rockets
fired from the separatist held areas
into
ukrainian government-controlled areas i
have visited the front lines i have been
supporting people there i have seen the
damage that russian rockets did to
apartment buildings and homes on the
ukrainian side and i can assume that
there was similar destruction on the
other side
none of this destruction is
comparable in any way to the level of
destruction that is being
leveled
at ukrainian cities today by the
russians not comparable what's going on
right now is a massive
war crime
another lie that's used by the russians
to justify their invasion of ukraine is
somehow according to putin the idea that
ukraine is ukrainians are russians
ukraine doesn't exist it has no history
of its own and so forth as someone who
has
by the way i'll interrupt this to say
that
link is contributing has contributed to
razzam for ukraine and i'll leave a link
in the description box which is a
ukrainian
website which is collecting donations to
help refugees to help displaced people
to help a variety of ukrainian
charities and we will continue to
support ukraine in a very modest way but
we are doing it we've changed our logo
we filled our logo in with the ukrainian
flag we are 100 behind the ukrainians
now
oh and i should have should add we're
going to find a way so that anyone who
wants to
learn ukrainian at link will be allowed
we'll be able to do so free of charge so
if you're interested in learning
ukrainian
stay with us we're going to figure out a
way so that you can access ukrainian and
not have to pay or to be a paying member
of link
we are also going to try to find a way
to make link available free of charge to
ukrainians particularly those who may
have fled to poland or or hungary or or
romania and need to learn those
languages until they're able to go back
to ukraine now getting back to i learned
ukrainian at linc
i became interested in uh you know 2014
when i saw what was going on there
and i have read
quite a bit about the history of ukraine
so let's address this other lie
that somehow ukraine is not a country
uh
about a thousand years ago
in what is today kiev
uh
we have the sort of formation of this
entity which is known to historians as
kiev and ruse
um
which according to some was founded by
viking marauders
uh at that time kiev was kind of on the
border between sort of iranian and
turkish-speaking step people and
this mass large group of slavs who lived
uh you know along the rivers
all the way up north to
novgorod and so forth
further north a greater influence of the
baltic and finnish type people further
south as i say this other these other
influences but there was one large
entity and i'm not a historian called
kevin ruse which was attacked by the
mongols and therefore
various principalities ended up being
uh subject to paying tribute to the
mongols but slowly the slavs came out
from under this starting with the
principality of
galicia and valine
uh which became sort of a a beach head
of this recovery of a a slavic identity
and they were ukrainians and from there
they spread out through other areas of
ukraine
uh and it was much later that muscovy
also achieved their independence from
the mongols
and then the moscowites expanded very
rapidly over a couple hundred years to
the pacific ocean and that became russia
but the two histories are different
and the um uh
ukrainian areas galicia baleen and
pardon me if i'm not a historian and
people will
find things to
complain about in my very brief summary
of ukrainian history but
lithuania then conquered these southern
slavic sort of eastern slavic lands
uh
and subsequently they allied lithuania
became allied with poland the
lithuanians were very tolerant
of a ruthenian or ukrainian belarusian
identity orthodox religion language and
the polish were less tolerant and as a
result over the course of uh several
hundred years uh
the
ruthenian speakers ukrainian speakers
they felt that they were oppressed by
the polls
and uh there was a cossack rebellion in
1650 i can't remember exactly
and the head of the cossacks uh manitsky
decided he would throw in his lot with
their fellow religionists
co-religionists the orthodox
uh christian russians
and from that point they became part of
the russian empire
based on some promise promises of
independence which were not uh honored
by the russians
a hundred years later uh large portions
of what is today ukraine were part of
poland and poland was then divided by
the great powers russia prussia
austro-hungary and so throughout this
whole period
ukraine was kind of splintered between
different uh
areas controlled by differing different
neighboring countries
but just like with so many other
national groups there was a national
awakening in the 19th century i read
about it when i was learning czech about
the czech national awakening we know
that in the balkans the serbs and the uh
bulgarians and the greeks also had their
period of national awakening this was a
major
current in the 19th century and the
ukrainians were no exception and
so when putin says that ukraine was a
creation of the soviet union that's an
absolute lie there was a major sort of
national feeling which the soviets knew
they had to
recognize in some way and therefore
and there were wars and there was in
fact briefly a separate you know
ukrainian republic again i don't
remember all the historical details uh
all i want to say is that ukraine when
you read the history it has an identity
of its own it has a language of its own
and the russians unfortunately not just
putin but many russians don't want to
admit that this is the case now
undoubtedly
uh when in 1991 the soviet union split
apart
uh and there was a there were
referendums throughout ukraine and the
ukrainians voted in favor of
independence now it i don't know the
background undoubtedly it reflected a
number of considerations including what
was happening in moscow
but they did vote for independence
and for many years after the
independence of ukraine they were still
very much
part of the old soviet
um
political uh
sphere
uh
and with different you know
with tensions
more nostalgic people for the soviet
union people more interested in a
western orientation
uh and all this while russia interfered
there was a two there was an election in
2004 when yushinko was elected uh
president and he was more he was a
western ukrainian i think
and he was more in favor of sort of a
stronger national identity for ukraine
there were people who were opposed to
him uh he was poisoned undoubtedly by
russian agents disfigured his face this
was the first of the orange revolutions
this kind of smoldered for a while
yanukovych came back in again
with plenty of russian interference in
uh ukrainian political affairs
and then there was this uh the maidan
revolution began 10 000 people
protesting in the maidan square in
kiev
and they were suppressed so brutally not
only by the police but also by what's
known as tatushkis which are thugs hired
by the government to kidnap and beat up
the demonstrators that there is
increasing sympathy for these
demonstrators eventually reaching a
million people so some people say well
the maidan was paid for by the u.s and
stuff you don't get a million people out
there by handing out cookies or whatever
the russian propaganda likes to pretend
the net result of which was that
yanukovych fled
he was afraid he didn't make a stand he
fled
and since then we've had two democratic
elections in ukraine people say it's
corrupt don't tell me there isn't
corruption everywhere yes there's
corruption in ukraine however there is a
very vibrant um
civic
society in ukraine there are people
trying to make ukraine better there are
people trying to line their pockets like
in most countries but it's a very was a
very vibrant country
and uh the suggestion
that uh those people and and the other
thing i want to again point out if you
look for it the speech by the uh
by the kenyan ambassador to the united
nations who makes the case that
at the end of every empire there are
undoubtedly people who end up in this
political you know unit country that
might have greater affinity for
similar people language groups ethnic
groups in the adjacent
part of some other country we cannot
keep revisiting these boundaries
if we did that and you're in in africa
we'd be at war all the time the same is
true with the
divisions that ended up between ukraine
and russia there are undoubtedly people
in eastern ukraine who feel sympathy
with russia who may feel more sympathy
with russia than with
kiev
it's not for russia to go in there and
foment a revolution it's not for
um
austria to go into the south tyrol where
undoubtedly at different times there
have been many german speakers in in
italy in that region of italy
south tyrol who would have wanted to be
part of austria
less so today but it's not for the
austrian army to go in there and foment
a revolution uh there has to be respect
for in fact russia promised ukraine
respect for their territorial integrity
uh respect of their uh independence on
two different occasions the budapest
memorandum and a treaty of friendship in
1997. so there is no justification
whatever sympathies with amongst
whatever percentage of the population in
whatever area of russia whatever those
sympathies might be that is for the
ukrainians to work out
uh and the ukrainians in their response
to this russian
uh uh
backed supported finance and not just
finance but the russian when it looked
like the ukrainians were going to take
it all back the russian army moved in
that's when we got the minsk agreement
so the russians have cons considered
this to be their project and they don't
have a right to make a project of
independence sentiments in neighboring
countries and the response of the
ukrainian army at that time was not a
genocide compared to the russian
approach to
independence uh an independence movement
in chechnya where they leveled grosnea
grozny this destroyed it
the ukrainian response was very measured
not without uh civilian casualties but
no genocide not a genocide
not a genocide like what the russians
did in chechnya and what the russians
are doing currently today in ukraine so
i had to make this video because i feel
very strongly i i follow it
you know i think about it every waking
minute i feel for the ukrainian people
and i think
everywhere people have to do everything
possible to help ukraine and to
basically and anyone in russia who is
not criticizing and trying to oppose
putin's war in my mind is complicit is
complicit if you say well stuff happens
and i don't know and both sides and
tensions and geopolitical and ukraine
shouldn't have tried to join nato that's
up to the ukrainians to decide if they
want to join nato or not join nato uh
the reason the countries of eastern
europe and the baltics wanted to join
nato is precisely for what we're seeing
right now because even in the 90s
influential russian politicians i think
of zidanovsky for one were constantly
threatening the baltics because
there is this messiah this this feeling
that somehow russia and its russian
civilization we have a right to have an
empire and all of this kind of
nationalistic imperialistic gobbledygook
is is
mainstream in russia and i think we have
to recognize that that's there and we
have to find ways
to persuade russians that there is no
future for them as some kind of
nostalgic imperialistic power
they are most welcome to be normal
members
of an international order where every
country large or small is respected it's
not just that we have to respect russia
russia has to respect even little
countries like estonia latvia
unfortunately there's a strong tendency
in russia not to do that and that's why
countries want to join nato okay i'm
going to run out of things to say here i
feel very strongly about this subject
please
find ways to help if you can contribute
to the red cross or rasam for ukraine or
whatever please do so i repeat anyone
who wants to learn ukrainian we're going
to find out ways to make that available
free at link
and
we're going to try to find ways to help
ukrainian refugees using free of charge
if they need to learn languages in order
to
you know fit in better into the
societies that they have
fled to so thank you for listening and
from the next videos will all be on
language learning bye